a Sci-Fi Western starring Bruce Campbell
an xfiles competitor that did it better
these shows may have been considered
failures at the time but they hold up
surprisingly well today kid-centric
horror was all the rage in the 9s from
Are You Afraid of the Dark to Goosebumps
and Beyond given the popularity of the
subgenre it's pretty surprising that
Erie Indiana was only a single season
Wonder especially when it was probably
the best of its kind to be released
during that era perhaps it's because it
was on NBC and had a prime time slot so
it needed to have major Network Prime
Time numbers to survive had it been an
afternoon show or on a less
discriminating Network it might have had
the longevity of deserved starring omry
cats Erie Indiana was about the titular
town and all of the bizarre goings on
that seem to always be happening there
sometimes the show tackled popular myths
like Elvis faking his own death to live
a private life while plenty of other
episodes were built around entirely new
and often extremely inventive scenarios
critics often reference creators like
Steph King and David Lynch in their
their Praise of the show let's go bag of
werewolf when that's done I'm taking aim
at this Warren Commission thing yes
sadly good reviews alone don't keep a
show on the air and Erie Indiana got
only 19 episodes before it was canceled
in
1993 another genre that was having a
moment in the '90s was sci-fi not only
did three different Star Trek series
overlap during the decade but shows like
the xfiles Babylon 5 Earth final
Conflict and sequest dsv all found an
audience and brought their own unique
spins to the genre there was even an
extremely successful sci-fi sitcom Third
Rock From the Sun that proved to have
surprising Acclaim in longevity for a
show with such a novelty type premise
but there were plenty that didn't make
it as well even ones that deserved to
one Hidden Gem that got lost in the
shuffle was Earth 2 another single
season NBC show that couldn't find the
viewership it needed despite strong
reviews even after earning three Emmy
nominations and winning the award for
visual effects taking place in the year
2192 the show imagined a few future
where Earth has become unlivable and
what remains of mankind is forced to
live on space stations trying to reach a
distant planet that seems to be
inhabitable beyond the dated special
effects Earth 2 remains watchable today
even if its depiction of a future
uninhabitable Earth feels even more
uncomfortably close now than it did in
1995 this one is a lot more wellknown
than most of the other shows on this
list and has had plenty of recognition
for what a great show it was and still
is but that doesn't change the fact that
Freaks and Geeks got a criminally short
run of only 18 episodes after its
September 1999 debut before NBC pulled
the pluck meanwhile critics were nearly
unanimous in their love for the show and
two different episodes were nominated
for outstanding writing in a comedy
series at the Emmys you want to make out
or something all guys want to make out
the Emmy that Freaks and Geeks actually
won outstanding casting for a comedy
series shouldn't come as a surprise
given that its Ensemble included
multiple soon to be a-listers there are
no shortage of coming of age shows that
look back at a previous generation but
Freaks and Geeks stood out both for its
honest depiction of the less popular
crowd as well as paying tribute to its
era without descending into parody oh
and its creator and executive producer
that would be Paul Fe and Jud appau
respectively who would become some of
the biggest comedic voices in Hollywood
a short time later plenty of cartoons
come and go in fact it's actually
somewhat rare for a kids cartoon to have
more than a season or two especially
during the '90s because that was usually
all that was needed to rerun it for the
next five plus years but there were
still a few that got cut short yet stuck
around long enough that they are still
looked back upon and still watched with
the same reverence as the likes of
Animaniacs and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles one of those shows is the
Pirates of Dark Water a Hanah barara
production that ran on the now defunct
Fox kids programming block Pirates hit
that rare older kid's younger teen Sweet
Spot flawlessly a hybrid of old school
swashbuckling pirate adventure with
hints of sci-fi and fantasy the show
started with an epic five-part
miniseries that told a much bigger story
than most cartoons at the time would
have even attempted only the five-part
Phoenix Saga from X-Men the Animated
Series came close in terms of ambition
and scope but like so many kids cartoons
that try to tell deeper more complex
stories with elaborate World building
not to mention having a higher Cali of
Animation than was typically seen on TV
at the time the Pirates of Dark Water
was not long for this world and got only
a single full season and an extremely
truncated second season before being
sunk and failure has only one reward
the P the P the pit cult film favorite
Bruce Campbell has long been just as
prolific on the small screen as he has
in movies most notably as a series
regular for all seven seasons of the Spy
based 2007 to 2013 action series burn
notice but the television role that's a
lot more in line with what people expect
from Campbell came nearly 15 years
earlier when he starred in the western
sci-fi comedy The Adventures of Brisco
County Jr in the show Campbell played
Brisco County a wise cracking Bounty
Hunter who doesn't seem particularly
good at his job but somehow always seems
to Fumble his way out of trouble created
by the writing team behind Indiana Jones
in the Last Crusade the show definitely
has elements of that film series with
clever writing and consistently
satisfying action
throughout where's Brisco Comet find
[Music]
Brisco that's what I thought you'd say
so what went wrong well it was perhaps a
bit too subversive for the time and
Campbell wasn't quite the household name
yet that he'd eventually become with his
loyal but still relatively Niche fan
base not yet large enough to sustain a
pricey Network television action
adventure show no one can deny the
impact the xfiles had on the Sci-Fi
genre and television as a whole yeah
that's a bleeping dead alien body if I
ever bleep and saw one the xfiles was a
huge series throughout its run and it
had other networks as well as Fox itself
trying to replicate the show's success
NBC took a crack at it with dark skies
which was dismissed by some critics as a
mere clone of the X Files due to just
how similar the two series were on the
other side of the coin there are some
particularly in retrospect who have made
the case that Dark Skies is actually the
superior of the two shows ultimately
Dark Skies didn't have the ratings to
Grant it more than 20 episodes causing
it to suffer the same fate as most
xfiles inspired shows but it was
arguably the best with a unique premise
that saw it taking place in an alternate
history 1960s in which aliens had been
on Earth since the' 40s with the
government having kept their existence a
secret from the public
it also didn't shy away from depicting
real people including politicians actors
musicians and more a lot of people
probably dismissed this show outright
based purely on the title since by 1997
a lot of people had grown tired of the
'90s marketing tactic of calling
everything
extreme extreme
dinosaurs plus the Ghostbusters brand
was languishing a bit at this point
years removed from the last movie or
previous cartoon series basically a lot
seemed to be working against extreme
Ghostbusters but the show itself was
great seemingly a kid show but with
enough depth and cleverness to the
writing and the stories to appeal to
adults as well it was the perfect show
for older fans of the franchise to watch
with their children as a means of
introducing it to them extreme
Ghostbusters also did a fantastic job at
introducing a new generation of
characters while also including the old
ones and having them all coexist and be
equally important to the plot lines
waiting on your signal Garrett and three
three
the show did get a commendable 40
episodes but it never got a second
season Prime Time sketch comedy on
regular Network television is something
that rarely works but that hasn't
stopped many from trying it over the
years including a group of young upand
comers in the early 90s that came
together to write and star in the Ben
Stiller show that's all right you can
get on you little lizard
King at Oliver stoneland we question
authority after getting it start on MTV
the version of the Ben Stiller show that
people are generally more aware of is
the one that ran on Fox for only 12
episodes leaving an unaired episode that
Comedy Central later added to its rerun
package of the show like most sketch
comedy the scenes could be a bit Hit or
Miss but the talent and chemistry of the
cast couldn't be denied the writing was
also worthy of an Emmy win even though
the show had already been canceled by
the time the crew took home their trophy
it's still worth looking back at these
soon to be Stars taking what is for most
of them their first real crack at an
on-screen career typically Saturday
night prime time is where networks put
shows that the execs aren't sure about
the rare shows that do well on a late
Saturday evening are usually aimed at
older viewers so when 1998's Cupid was
launched in the 10 p.m. Saturday time
slot by ABC it was pretty clear the
network didn't fully believe in it the
series followed a man named Trevor hail
who is convinced that he's the
mythological God Cupid but is
institutionalized but that does allow
him to meet Claire a psychologist who
doesn't fully believe Trevor but does
decide to roll the dice and set him free
to to complete his mission to bring 100
couples together at which point he
claims Zeus will reinstate his powers
and let him return to Mount Olympus we
never learned if Trevor was telling the
truth as Cupid was canceled after only
15 episodes interestingly Cupid was
revived in 2009 with a similar premise
but a new cast and that one only got
half the episodes of its
predecessor MTV's liquid television was
a series that ran sporadically during
the first half of the 1990s and would
feature various clips of animated
projects some would be one and done
while others became recurring segments
on the show and though the vast majority
sadly died with the show a few did wind
up turning into full-fledged series of
their own most notably Beavis and
Butthead and Eon flux in the same year
that liquid television signed off MTV
launched a series called Oddities which
expanded the liquid television format by
giving each animated project an entire
minseries of fulllength episodes the
first was the bizarre and ultimately
forgettable the head but that was
followed by the excellent and certainly
before its time the max based on the
comic series of the same name its main
character was a homeless man looked
after by a social worker named Julie in
the real world who also lived in an
alternate reality where he was a
powerful Warrior tasked with protecting
the Jungle Queen who was that reality's
version of Julie he was aware of the two
realities while she was not he just may
be out of his mind it was one of the few
darker comic adaptations to exist at the
time predating HBO Spawn series by
several years while it was technically
only meant to be a limited series had it
been more popular it might have earned a
couple of full
seasons The Dana Carvey Show seemed like
it had the potential to Buck the curse
of the Prime Time sketch comedy show
first and foremost it was headlined by
you guessed it Dana Carvey who was only
a few years off his award-winning run as
one of the most popular performers in
Saturday Night Live history that should
have given it a leg up over say the Ben
Stiller show which was led by an actor
that most of America hadn't heard of yet
but despite the clout and talent of car
Carvey in addition to a cast that
included both Steve Carell and Steven
colar The Dana Carvey Show fell into the
pit of failure like so many other Prime
Time sketch comedies rather than play it
safe and be an extension of his SNL work
though there was some of that the show's
humor was often abstract weird and often
a little too gross for Prime Time
audiences it's the kind of thing that
has often thrived on cable but it was
way too out there for the 90 sitcom
crowd and only got eight episodes the
days are rushing by children it'll over
before you know
it in the wake of The Simpsons becoming
not only a hit television show but an
entire pop culture Behemoth a whole new
wave of prime time animation kicked off
in a big way during the '90s but for
every South Park and King of the Hill
there were dozens of shows that came and
went so quickly that barely anyone
noticed or remembers them to be honest
most of them weren't a huge loss but
there were some that deserved more
success the excellent Mission Hill got
only a single season in 13 episodes to
find its audience it didn't bother to
have kid characters or be about families
focusing instead on the lives of teens
and young adults it was also the
unfortunate victim of airing on the WB
the now defunct Network that couldn't
even reach its 12th birthday like many
gone to soon animated shows it saw
increased visibility when reruns hit
adult swim in 2002 but that wasn't
enough to revive the show those original
13 episodes are all will'll ever have to
enjoy one of the biggest Pioneers in the
sketch comedy genre was the Carol
Bernett show which ran from 1967 to 1978
and helped to establish many elements of
the genre that are followed to this day
particularly the shows that are filmed
in front of an audience and Bernette
herself would be a Trailblazer once
again 12 years later with Carolyn
company what set carollyn company apart
from most sketch shows up to that point
is that rather than multiple short
sketches within an episode each episode
was a single extended sketch modern
shows have certainly used the format but
this was one of the Trailblazers with
two seasons and 33 episodes Carol and
Company lasted longer than most shows on
this list but it still wasn't as long as
it
deserved author Elmore Leonard saw a lot
of screen adaptations of his works
during his life including popular films
like 310 to Yuma out of sight Jackie
Brown and Get Shorty to name a few but
one adaptation that's been lost to time
is 1998's maximum Bob the Bob in
question is Judge Bob Gibbs who earns
his nickname via his tendency to always
seek the maximum sentence for the
defendants in the case he presides over
no matter the crime pending your appeal
until such time as a date can be set for
your
execution for drinking a beer but this
was no generic courtroom show maximum
Bob was compared to more offbeat shows
like Twin Peaks and Northern Exposure by
critics at the time that's because in
addition to Bob there was also his wife
a former mermaid performer turned
psychic the cast of wacky characters
goes on from there all surrounding Bob
and challenging his small-minded
conservative sensibilities we probably
don't need to explain why this
delightfully bizarre show didn't find
the audience it needed to last more than
seven
episodes J Moore starred is floundering
Hollywood producer Peter dragon in the
subversive satire action an unflinching
look at the movie business and the
thickle nature of Fame action was a
network television series with cable
Ambitions pushing the boundaries of what
was typically seen and heard on one of
the major networks it would go down in
history as the first fox show to be
rated tvma something that was unusual at
the time for non cable shows do you
think any major Network would put this
on without censoring pixelating and
bleeping the hell out of
it you bet your ass they would critics
were generally positive on the show and
even many of the negative reviews
praised the accuracy with which action
mocked its targets but ultimately found
it too mean to be enjoyable Fox canceled
action after airing only eight of its 13
filmed episodes the unaired episodes
along with the original 8 would later
run on cable channels like FX Comedy
Central and IFC all of which would have
been a better home for the series in the
first place nowadays you'd be lucky to
find the show anywhere with a generic
title it's even tough to search for
another great show that was the victim
of the 9s was the 1995 to 96 Sci-Fi
series Noir man airing on UPN Noir man
never really had a chance the show
followed a photographer named Thomas Vil
who wakes up one day to find that none
of his friends or family seem to know
who he is including his own wife who now
has a different husband who are you
what do you
want it's not funny Thomas sets out to
discover why his existence has
essentially been erased deducing that it
may have something to do with a photo
he's taken ratings started off well
enough but they dropped off sharply as
the first season went on that combined
with creative struggles behind the
scenes led to the show's demise after
only 25 episodes as long as you're okay
with watching a series that doesn't have
a resolution and never will nowhere man
is one of the most overlooked shows of
its kind from that era
in Stark graving mad which debuted in
the fall of 1999 Tony shaloo is a quirky
horror novelist and Neil Patrick Harris
is his phobia prone editor the two being
forced to find a way to make their
partnership click is admittedly just
another variation on The well-worn Odd
Couple theme but it works dueing no
small part to the talent of the two
actors and their terrific chemistry
together but this was the era when
friends was in full swing and Seinfeld
had just finished with a historic series
finale the bar was extremely high in
terms of the ratings that were expected
of a prime time Network sitcom on top of
that NBC put the show in direct
competition with the first season of
ABC's Who Wants To Be A Millionaire
which of course was becoming a
full-blown phenomenon at the time and
was going to demolish pretty much
anything that tried to take it on is
that your final answer needless to say
Stark rving mad was canceled after one
season another too weird for prime time
show was Fox's get a life a surreal
comedy starring and co-created by Chris
Elliot Elliot plays Manchild Chris
Peterson who at 30 still lives at home
still has the same paper route he had as
a kid and still doesn't have a driver's
license while that might seem like the
premise for a fairly standard sitcom get
a life was anything but with episodes
about everything from finding a vomiting
alien which Chris barbecues and eats
later in the episode to Chris
inexplicably discovering he can see a
few seconds into the future oh and Chris
is also killed in 12 of the show's 35
episodes that tastes
weird uh-oh wrong bottle
ratings were never great for the show
but get a life was actually given a
second season it's easy to see in
hindsight how ahead of its time the show
was plus how influential it would be for
the blossoming alt comedy movement on TV
and it's a blast to watch today with
that perspective there was an
embarrassment of riches in the 1990s for
cartoon watching comic book fans in
addition to the biggies like Batman the
Animated Series Spider-Man and X-Men the
Animated Series there seemed to be a
handful of animated comic adaptations on
the air at any given time that were well
worth watching there were so many in
fact that there just weren't enough
viewers to keep them all afloat and a
few great ones slipped through the
cracks running for only 3 months and 13
episodes in 1998 Silver Surfer wasn't
just the best of the Lesser remembered
comic book cartoons but is one of the
best of the era period mimicking Jack
Kirby's art style with a combination of
handdrawn and computer animation the
show already set itself apart with a
look that was both retro and also
futuristic at the same time time though
the Fantastic Four were disappointingly
absent despite their connection to the
character in the comics the show did
bring in classic characters like galatis
ego The Living Planet and The Watcher it
was also a bit heavier than most of its
peers and willing to address complex
political and social issues which most
Comics did but much of which was lost
when transforming the properties into
kid-friendly cartoons frustratingly it
wasn't low ratings that led to the
demise of Silver Surfer but rather a
rights dispute better to perish for what
I believe leave him then endure forever
as a traitor to life like Freaks and
Geeks my so-called life has been on so
many lists of shows canceled too soon
and has been rebroadcast so many times
in so many different places since its
initial run that it almost feels
pointless to Spotlight it here but this
list isn't only meant to highlight shows
that people might have forgotten about
or never knew existed the key angle here
is that these shows are still worth a
watch and boy is my so-called life
certainly still worth a watch while it's
depiction of teen life Circ of the men
'90s might feel very much of its time
particularly when it comes to the music
the clothing and the overall vibe there
is still a Timeless quality to The Angst
depicted in the show every generation of
current or former teenagers can find
themselves in one of the show's
characters that's a big part of the
reason why my so-called life has
sustained such a lasting Legacy for
nearly 30 years since its cancellation
after a run of only 19
episodes